President Trump appears to have been the
victim of a prank phone call it happened
this week while he was aboard Air Force
One and while the White House isn't
commenting on the matter the audio has
been posted online in a podcast the
phone call was apparently placed on
Wednesday while President Trump was
flying back from a campaign rally in
Fargo North Dakota the prankster
podcast host and former Howard Stern
Show staffer John Melendez better known
as stuttering John's on the six-minute
call meléndez claims to be New Jersey
Democratic Senator Bob Menendez and he
appears to engage the President and a
number of pressing issues including
immigration and the president's pending
decision on naming a Supreme Court
justice nominee to replace the retiring
Anthony Kennedy at one point in the
alleged conversation the president
congratulate Stu the senator on his
recent acquittal on corruption charges
when asked to confirm if the president
was on the call a White House official
tells CBS News we are not engaging on
this at all in a statement senator
Menendez tells CBS News I welcome any
opportunity to have a real conversation
with the President on how to uphold the
American values that guided our
family-based immigration policy for the
past century you know the first thing I
thought was one why would he take the
call
it sounded like he likes Bob Menendez
the center and you think
very congenial but what was it the Bob
Menendez had it's just anxious
fascinating that you can dial a number
not just any number Air Force one
because the White House
you know switchboard is available to any
American right the Air Force one phone
number
how did stuttering John get that well or
that he went through the switchboard how
did they get that to the president
without doing any yeah so fasten they
went from the switchboard at the White
House tonight call in that right and
Jared Kushner took the call think
somebody's gonna be answering some
questions about that will be interested